i remember one time i was hanging out
with jeff mother's basement
sorry jeff i'm gonna i'm gonna kill you
out for for this but i remember
um we were i think it was at an ax party
yeah and we were talking about
like how how like how much create like
some some crazy [ __ ] that we've done
yeah and i was talking about oh yeah
it's like downing a pint of cocaine
i'm like yeah that's not how you do
cocaine
i was just like it was just just the
blinking memes like
that's that's not how cocaine's done you
know you don't down a pint of cocaine
have you down the plane of anything
it's like he's like oh my god so yeah
thank you for that jeff i'm definitely
gonna be using that
in the future and the subreddit is
definitely gonna be using that so i
guarantee
it's like downing a pint of cocaine
talking about snorting a line of heroin
to get to the actual topic that we were
going to talk about before we went on
this massive tangent as we always do
um i guess we wanted to talk about food
right guys
because food i i love food who doesn't
love food i only exist
i love consuming things in my mouth
that came out really wrong
yeah um i guess the reason i wanted to
bring this up is joey you
recently chose to become a pescetarian
yes but let me explain like a
pescetarian in like inverted comics yes
yes
so i i i didn't decide to like fully
transition
because i like meat too much yes but i
figured
just for about a month aki and i were
like let's see if we can be pescatarian
because
i feel if there's any country that is
perfect to be a pescetarian it would be
japan
because yeah pescetarian if you don't
know means it's basically vegetarian but
you can also eat fish yeah
um fish on animals they don't have souls
yeah exactly they're not that's not
real meat breathing so uh yeah so
i figured just as like uh not so much
like as a morality thing but more just
to better my diet and just eat a little
bit healthier we were like okay let's
let's try and be pescetarian for like
one month because
it's going to be the la so basically my
last month of my 25th year
is gonna be me as a pescatarian and then
on my 26th birthday at the end of
september i'm gonna be like give me
all the meat give me everything eating
meat i don't want to see a piece of
greenery
on my plate dude when i was like i feel
like i was raised where
if the meal didn't have meat in it it's
not a meal yeah
that's that's that's that's how i feel
maybe that's like a is that a british
thing
i don't think so i think it's an asian
thing as well yeah like i i remember i
i i still to this day i i cannot get
full unless i have
some kind of meat give me a crunch a
crumb of chicken like i do
count fish as meat but if i just have no
meat yeah there needs to be like
something dead on my place
no that's how it is i need something
dead on my plate unless like because
i've tried having like vegetarian meals
and then
i get filled up and then i get hungry an
hour later
without fail yeah yeah i mean it's i
guess and i don't know if that's like a
mental thing
to be my body's like there's probably
some diet expert watching us who can
explain
i'm just gonna we're gonna go off all
anecdotal evidence right so don't take
anything we say seriously
yeah yeah so basically yeah i figured
you know i like fish a lot and japan is
such a seafood heavy country yeah
you could walk down the road and get
some sushi or get you know go to the
supermarket and buy
pre-cooked fish yeah stuff like that
right and all of it tastes so [ __ ]
good
it's also also adapted to worry about it
here i feel like i
dude whenever someone ordered like
oysters or [ __ ] in a like not
extremely expensive place in the uk i'm
like bro all right yeah oysters are like
you never
order oysters unless you trust the place
you're ordering oysters
it's like also if the curry place the
indian carry place
don't [ __ ] with that that's always
that's always a question no matter what
at least in the uk that is a [ __ ]
gamble unless you have a place and even
even if you have a place you're like but
do they treat the seafood correctly yeah
they've probably got it i need to have
seen this fish die
in my face i don't think i feel like
there are some certain cuisines
like like in the uk in the uk like
in thailand especially like street food
in thailand
tastes amazing but would you trust it
for like
to pass hygienic tests not exactly but
it doesn't stop it from tasting
you take that risk some of the dirtiest
looking places
taste the best it's true i don't know
why but it's like an ax right when
you're walking down a x and those hot
dog stands are there
oh yeah and they've had these hot dogs
in these like cardboard packaging
and it's been out there all [ __ ] day
yeah and then they just chuck them on
the grill and sure it looks amazing on
the grill right but like
those have been soggy for like eight
hours yeah dude they smell [ __ ] nice
they smell amazing but it it's like what
is it like the [ __ ] succubuses right
on like all the
stories right they they look amazing
right yeah it's too good to be true
don't your stomach's gonna hate you
the only people every time someone gets
sick at a convention it's always because
they go to the hospital
it's always the same they always eat one
of those things i'm like why did you do
it they're like it just looks so good
i couldn't help myself and it's like
dumb [ __ ] there is like a denny's there
was like
everything around here okay i'm not
saying actually there's literally a
chick-fil-a down there
i say that but denny's is probably a
gamble as well yeah in america
definitely
yeah but i kind of had a similar thing
uh in the philippines with street food
because
because i i you know the one time i went
to the philippines to go see aki's
family i
was like you know there's all this
amazing looking street food but yeah
i feel if i don't make the right choice
i'm probably just gonna die
on the road so it's really weird i did
uh
like get uh not food poisoning but i
definitely got like some bad diarrhea
from one on the street yeah
but it was from a mango
wow yeah which is weird right you
wouldn't expect i don't really do you
like that man
it was like
you would think that that would get me
sick but no
okay it wasn't the fetus it was a
[ __ ] mango
i can understand if you've like grown up
with food like that but how can you like
you know as like an australian japanese
dude see a [ __ ] like
like a bird yeah just just be like yo
[ __ ] that looks tasty bro give me two
of those hey man arki's dad was like
yeah that [ __ ] tastes good i'm like all
right i trust you
and so i bought two is that is that the
weirdest thing you've eaten
it's probably the weirdest thing i've
eaten i trust people
when they say that but i'm looking at
them the whole time like i do not expect
anything from this i'm going to eat it
just to entertain you
but i'm expecting this to taste like
[ __ ] i mean yeah i filmed a video on it
as well it's only a second channel but
like
i went hot because apparently aki told
me that like oh yeah this is like one of
the
you know fear factor right yeah the
american shark apparently uh she said
that oh uh this ballot stuff
yeah it's like one of the last foods
that they eat on fear factor it's like
if you can't i'm [ __ ] you can eat
anything i'm like but it's just the duck
fetus
i'll eat it i'm just not going to be
happy about it i looked at that
[ __ ] dead in the end
wake up wake up i was like i was like
yes you are going into my stomach
it's like in japan they have this at the
sushi restaurant normally fish
restaurants they have like the sperm
sack
and this [ __ ] is disgusting yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and even when you speak to japanese
they're like yo you either just despise
that [ __ ] or you love it
yeah it's in a quiet time it is quiet it
looks like a brain
that has lost all the water like like
it's falling apart right it's all
untangled bro yeah and it's just yeah
and then when someone's like what is it
what is it oh no just try it and then
you try and like oh it's a sperm sack
yeah and with the sperm in it and it
tastes like how you would imagine a
spider
would taste it does feel like you just
got [ __ ] in the mouth
like no no it totally does because i
remember i i remember like the weirdest
thing
like i would say i'd had was like in
china where it's
you know like i was with a friend and
their family
and i don't know what it is i i don't
know if this is an asian thing but
whenever they see a foreigner
trying like they always ordered like the
most exotic food and then try to get
them to try it right
my parents do exactly the same and
uh their family did exactly the same to
me so they were ordering all this weird
[ __ ] and then
they ordered this soup and they tell me
oh try the soup it's just beef soup
right so i started chowing down on this
beef soup
and then i was like um this is this is
all right this is all right and then i
get to this like
really chewy chewy parts that i have to
like really
like my way through right i'm like oh
what is this and had like the most awful
like aftertaste you can imagine right
it just like it just like stayed in your
mouth forever
and then i asked them what the hell was
that chewy bit and then and
then my friend asked you know their
family and they translate it to me
and they said oh no that's probably the
bulls testicles i'm like
i'm like bruh hold on a second what what
is this
oh this is a bull's peanut soup and i'm
just like
why did you not why did you not lead
with that australia yeah this feels like
information i should have been told at
the start of this meal
they knew exactly what they were doing
they were like oh this is beef soup this
is beef soup you can have this
i don't know i'm i'm one of those people
who would not be mad
at that kind of stuff just because i
want to dick bro yeah i want to i want
to try all the weird [ __ ] like because i
know i do as well
yeah because i know right i know if i
went to a restaurant like that by myself
and i looked at the menu and i saw a
bull's penis testicle
i bought people's pieces oh my god
that was a thousand she's always like
salivating
sorry i was like that it's like people
like that right i'm like yeah order it
i'm gonna look you in the eye i'm gonna
eat this [ __ ] i want you to know that
i'm gonna eat it and i'm gonna tell you
it tastes like [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna
i'm not gonna give you the satisfaction
again like if i saw that on the menu
i probably wouldn't order it myself
right
there's no way the beef burger yeah yeah
yeah something that i'm familiar with so
i would rather someone just order me
some weird [ __ ] and then trick me into
eating it so that i could be like well
i may not
well i may not have you know enjoyed it
but hey now i can say that i've eaten
balls testicles yeah you know i don't
think i'd be very happy if someone had
been like hey that's a dick and i'm like
i'll be like to be fair they disguise it
very well you know sometimes he's a gay
it didn't look like a dick because it
was like all minced up into like a ball
oh i don't think they would just chop up
me like there we go
it's just like a full dick i'm like what
is this
oh it's uh it's it's just ball meat and
i'm like
what kind of what kind of ball made that
that looks very much like a testicle
i think the problem is with stuff like
this for me and i'm sure a lot of people
can relate to this
i don't want my [ __ ] meals to be a
[ __ ] like adventure game for someone
dude i just want to eat
bro yeah sometimes i just want to enjoy
my meal have a nice time i want to skip
the story right yeah
and not not turn into like a [ __ ]
bear grylls tv show in the middle of
this restaurant you know what i mean
like yeah i hate it when people try and
do that they're like try this try this
awful thing i'm like why would i try
that awful thing
you've just told me it's awful why are
you trying to make it
opposite i will happily be like yeah
yeah yeah yeah joey's that guy in a
restaurant who just like orders the
weirdest [ __ ] yeah yeah you and aki both
do it you
we're sitting down they'll be like so
who ordered the slime [ __ ]
oh i like that and i'm like that's a lie
you don't like it you're just ordering
it to make yourself look like you're
[ __ ] bad girls at this izakaya
just admit it okay admit it no one likes
it and i love i love the fact that every
time we get to that moment
every time without fail you're like do
you guys want to try some
and every time we just say no joey that
doesn't look appetizing
i want you guys to try it joey finishes
what is it what is this good
[ __ ] you always get what is it another
goop it's like oh yeah it's [ __ ]
awful yeah it's like
it's a like uh octopus that and wasabi
and you're putting in a blender yeah
i've never seen any japanese person
order it around me so what i mean i have
plenty of japanese people
why do you think it's like a staple menu
at izakaya no no it's on the bottom dude
and then after that there's this other
like fish that i i don't know how they
prepare it but
it's just got the consistency of a tire
with no taste
oh the toenail yeah yeah it's like the
toenail yeah
it tastes it tastes and looks like a
toenail and it feels like a toenail
it has the concealer it's ray it's a
stingray stingray
fin right yeah it's the kind of thing
where it's like yeah sure when i'm drunk
enough i'll chew on it and i'll have no
complaints but when it's like i want to
have a meal
why would i fill myself up with
something that doesn't taste like
anything and takes me 10 minutes to eat
and just frustrates me you had that the
other day right when we went to a
restaurant and i ordered
um
like it's zero calories and i'm like so
what if it's zero calories well because
you're always on about like how many
calories does this no no
i'm just thinking like some sometimes
you know in a meal you're like all right
i don't want to kill myself right yeah
my dad my dad uh described that at once
as eating an eraser
yeah that's pretty much what it looks
like